Ціяскраві сміттєвозкивже кілька місяців курсують
вулицямиБерлінаі збирають сміття.
Автомобіль прикрашенийнаписом, що він "не є курцем" -
дотепний натяк на те, щомашина працює на водні,
а тому не забруднює повітря.
Помітити відмінність зовні важко, але різниця є.
Цяавтівкатихіша. Є лишефоновий шум.Можна навітьвідчути
коженкамінчик під шиною.
Сміттєвозка працює майже безшумно, оскільки центральнимелементом
єелектродвигунна 250кіловат.
Струмдо ньогоподаютьпаливніелементи,котріживлятьсязадопомогою
водню. Крім того,на бортузавждиє батарея,
яказаряджаєтьсяенергією,щовиробляєтьсяпідчасгальмування.
Щоправда, таких інноваційних сміттєвозок на водні в автопарку
Берлінської комунальної служби BSR лише шість.
Це, звісно, мізер, якщо врахувати, що всього в її розпорядженні
понад 1800автомобілів.
Однак таке придбання саме по собі важливий крок у напрямку
активного використання енергоносія майбутнього.
Так для водневих сміттєвозоккомунальній службі довелося підготуватиінфраструктуру.
Електромобілюпотрібнаінфраструктурадля зарядки.
Вона нам потрібна була ще раніше ідляіншихавтомобілів.
Миготувались, щобу насбуливідповіднізасобизарядкиі була інфраструктура.
Інша річ - заправкаводнем.Наразі питання розбудови
водневих заправокна власній територіїдля цього автопаркуне стоїть,
аджеавтівокна воднітутще замало.
Ми можемо використовувати наявні в місті водневі заправні станції.
Поки їх у Берліні дві, третя будується. Ми впевнені, що зі збільшенням
кількості транспортних засобів, що працюють на паливних елементах,
ми зможемо користуватися ними постійно і щодня.
Водневісміттєвозкиє не лише в Берліні.
Німецька автомобільна компаніяFaunз містечкаОстергольц-Шармбек,
що під Бременом,вжевиробила 20 схожих автомобілів
на водні для різних міст Німеччини.
Підприємство вже 15 років займаєтьсявиробництвомавтівокз паливними елементами.
Ще у 2011 роцітут виробилиперший прототип,
що два роки курсував вулицями Берліна.
Після удосконалення і усуненнянедоліківфірмапредставилау Мюнхені
нову версіюсміттєвозкина водніу 2018 році.
Чи не найцікавіший варіант робити сміттєвозки на водні представлений у Вупперталі.
Сміттєспалювальний завод там виробляє водень на власному електролізері.
Машина у Вупперталі збирає сміття, в'їжджає на підприємство,
і там виробляється водень на сміттєспалювальному заводі
з викинутого сміття шляхом електролізу.
Так можна заправити автівку воднем знову, уникнувши викидів у повітря.
Недолікводневихсміттєвозок- їхнявисокаціна.
Якщо звичайний автомобіль для збору сміття коштує близько 250 тисяч євро,
то за авто, що працює на водні, доведеться викласти втричі більше.
Такі транспортні засоби з’являються на ринку лише завдяки субсидіюванню.
І наше завдання на майбутнє - знизити витрати на такі транспортнізасоби,
щоб цей автомобіль став ринковим і був доступним без субсидій.
Берлінcькакомунальна службазмогла придбати водневісміттєвозки
завдякипрограмі "Чисте повітря" міністерства транспорту,
якачастково профінансувала закупівлюцихтранспортнихзасобів.
Програматакож покрила80%всіхдодатковихвитрат,
що виникли при закупівлі екологічного транспорту.
Грошіна фінансування таких проєктіву Німеччині походять зі спеціальної програми
федерального уряду з реалізації національної водневої стратегії.
Бюджет цієї програми становить загалом дев'ять мільярдів євро.
Їїнадзавдання- поєднатипромисловий розвиток країни і захист глобального клімату.
Стратегія передбачає значне зменшення викидіввуглекислого газу
до 2030 і 2050 років.
Експерти ставляться до стратегії схвально, але кажуть, щоїїцілі
мають бути ще амбітнішими.
Стратегія не має недоліків, алевона не дуже амбітна.
На даний момент для цієї стратегії оголошено великі суми фінансування,
частина вжереалізована у конкретних програмах фінансування…
Але чогоцій стратегії бракує, такцечіткоговизначення умов
нормативно-правової бази, які дозволятьздійснювати торгівлюбез субсидій.
Воднева стратегія передбачаєвикористаннясаме"зеленого" водню.
Тобто такого водню,для виробництваякого для електролізу
використовуватимутьлишеструм з відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Водень і зелений струм- цедва енергоносії майбутнього.
Єдині, якідійсно невиділяють вуглекислий газ.
Німеччині і надалі доведеться імпортувати енергію.
Тільки замість нафти та природного газу, які імпортуються сьогодні,
у майбутньому це будеводень.
Однією зперевагімпортуводню для Німеччиниє те, що країні
більше не требаскуповуватинафту чи природній газлишеутихкраїнах,
де є родовища. Забезпечити себе воднем Німеччина зможе завдяки
імпорту зеленого струмузкраїн, де єумови для його виробництва,
або імпортуючивжеготовий"зелений"водень. Зокрема і з України.
У Німеччині ми маємо перевагу, бо можемо самівизначати,
звідкибуденадходитинашводень.
Миможемоінвестувативкраїни,яківважаємополітичностабільними
іяківироблятимутьнашводеньумайбутньому.
Українамаєвеличезнітериторії.Маєбагатосонця.
Там єтрубопровіднамережа для природного газуміжУкраїноютаНімеччиною.
Ми могли бтранспортуватинею неприроднийгаз, аводень.
Незалежно від того, звідки Німеччина братиме готовий водень
чи"зелений" струмдля його виробництва,у Німеччині активно
розвиваються проєкти пов’язані з воднем.
У комунальній службі прибирання Берліна вже наближають майбутнє.
Електричний привід завжди має недолік,аджеакумулятори важкі.
Ось чомудля важкихавтівокмайбутнєу цьомутипі автомобіля,
де єелектропривід, щопідтримуєтьсяпаливними елементами.
2022 року в автопарку берлінських комунальників
мають з'явитися ще вісім автівокна водні.